opinions expressed on this program are
those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group
you never sign your signature exactly
the same way
tonight on politics now election
officials tell us how they compare
signatures on ballots
and if the process they use rather when
they don't match
suzy lee is attacking me she's attacking
my family
on tv nonstop we dig into congressional
district three the race for that seat
where republican dan rodimer defends
himself against allegations he's
dangerous and
violent plus basically he's running on a
record
of basically being pro-trump and he's
holding on to those coattails incumbent
congresswoman susie lee responds to
attacks
she's a puppet for speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
early voting for the general election is
officially underway in nevada thank you
for joining us here on politics now i'm
john langler
so early voting started today it runs
until october
30th there are 48 in-person voting
locations
however the dates and the times for them
here in clark county vary so
check them out at eightnewsnow.com first
mail-in ballots are also
out some have already been returned you
can drop them off at the in-person
locations
or just put them in the mail here in
clark county more than 1.2 million
ballots were sent out
516 thousand democrats 357 000 to
registered republicans
388 000 were sent to registered
nonpartisan or
other parties so far forty seven
thousand ballots have been returned
about four percent
the breakdown you see on your screen
twenty seven thousand by democrats
nine thousand by republicans and ten
thousand by non-partisan voters
not a large amount but democrats are
taking a big
early lead we have been getting a lot of
questions from you
about election integrity president
donald trump has questioned nevada's
process
and says it might be stolen the concern
is about the mail-in ballots and whether
they could lead to fraudulent votes
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
closer look at signature verification
[Music]
each signature on each ballot in nevada
must be verified
the first step in that process is
running it through our mail ballot
processing system
registrar joe gloria says in clark
county each ballot is scanned
software determines whether the voter's
signature matches the signature on file
from multiple sources
like voter registration or even a
driver's license
if the machine rejects the ballot
election workers take a look
if two workers decide the signatures do
not match
they are advised to contact the voter we
must
statutorily contact that voter and give
them an opportunity to cure that ballot
gloria says a voter can respond through
the secretary of state's
app where they can sign an affidavit and
provide their nevada driver's license or
id or through the registrar they can
provide answers to three questions about
personal information so their ballot is
counted
for a ballot to be rejected in the first
place
there has to be significant differences
you
never sign your signature exactly the
same way
two times there's always going to be
slight little differences but the
counties are looking
for those indicators
of differences and if there's multiple
of those and significant then the
signature will be rejected wayne thorley
is the deputy secretary of state for
elections
is that enough to prevent voter fraud it
is
and it's also no different than
identification
that is done at the polling place
signature verification is
not unique to voting by mail if we were
doing exclusively in-person voting we
would be verifying voters identities
by signature also when a person goes to
the polling place
they are asked to sign the roster also
called a poll book
and then that signature they put on the
poll book or the roster
is compared to the signature that the
county has on file for the voter
during the primary more than 12 thousand
ballots were initially rejected about
two and a half percent of the total
number of votes according to the
secretary of state's office
nearly 7 000 were not counted because
they couldn't be resolved
gloria says the machines in clark county
are programmed
the same way they were for the primary
how can you explain
what the margin of error is that's
difficult to do
if it meets the requirement that there's
an algorithm in place that the system
uses for the first check
after that there's forensic training
that my staff goes through that they
pass on to the
election staff that goes through and
verifies those signatures
thorley says the secretary of state's
office does not check voting machines in
clark county because there's no law
requiring that
oversight he also says secretary of
state barbara sagavski has been
an advocate for a voter id requirement
which does not exist
in nevada vanessa murphy 8 news now
now we have information on how you can
register to vote and a lot more about
the election at eightnewsnow.com
meanwhile the presidential campaign
wound its way through las vegas this
week on monday ivanka trump president
trump's daughter
she stopped at legends ranch near
windmill and las vegas boulevard
campaigning for her father
she spoke with former white house press
secretary hogan gidley about
manufacturing jobs in the country
former secretary of state and one-time
democratic presidential candidate john
kerry campaigned as you see here
on behalf of joe biden in las vegas he
told the i-team's david charns
biden administration would support
recent peace deals between israel and
other middle eastern countries
would the bodine administration continue
to uphold those deals and is this
something that
you know joe biden um in kamala harris
support
absolutely joe biden and kamala both
welcomed the initiative of the united
arab emirates the uae
they took the initiative they're the
ones who live in the region they're the
ones who get the flack if there is flack
and they had the courage to stand up and
do and to
actually sort of cement what had already
been a changing relationship with the
state of israel
but joe biden is is a very very
pro-israel there's a long record of
support for israel
and of course other candidates and other
members of the different campaigns were
in las vegas as well donald trump jr was
in las vegas on wednesday night
in the northeastern part of the valley
at an engineering firm called civil
works
trump jr told eight news now the ways
his father
is covet diagnosis has influenced his
opinion on the virus
anyone who goes around him has to be
tested on a daily basis
literally and he was still able to get
it but he was also you know he's a 74
year old guy that probably eats a little
too much mcdonald's and
he walked out in two days so i think you
can take it seriously you can take
reasonable precautions
about 150 people attended that event and
it included speeches from other
prominent nevada gop leaders
including state party chair michael
mcdonald
we put the full interviews with john
kerry donald trump jr and others on our
website
just look for the 2020 election
interviews tab at eightnewsnow.com and
you can watch all of the interviews
from other candidates as well senate
confirmation hearings for supreme court
nominee judge amy coney barrett wrapped
up on thursday in washington
on capitol hill judge barrett declined
to answer many questions from democratic
senators
she said she didn't want to prejudge an
issue that might come up in a case
meanwhile republicans spent the hearings
defending her
i would be afraid to ask her about the
presence of gravity on earth
she may decline to answer because it may
come up in a case
certainly there is nothing about this
nominee
that can be left
as suggesting that she's anything other
than an extraordinarily gifted jurist
democrats claim they haven't had
adequate time to review judge barrett's
nomination
the question is well what stood out
let's ask our washington dc
correspondent alexander limon with a
look at
what we've learned from the hearings
during the week and
what came up that could derail the
nomination moving forward alex
hey there well i would say that one of
the things that really stood out is how
different these confirmation hearings
were
compared to brett kavanaugh's
confirmation hearings you know they were
a lot more
civil and cordial the interactions
between the senators
and the nominee and also a lot more
informative we did learn
a little bit about her her family her
past her time
on the seventh court of appeals and also
about her faith that was something that
came up
a lot she is a catholic and she is
pro-life
but the argument that republican
senators tried to mount here is that she
can
and has in her past separate her
personal
religion and her views from her rulings
on the court that she takes her job very
seriously
and that she will be able to do that on
the other hand democrats
say they highly doubt that they have
their doubts in part because president
trump has tweeted
a lot that he expects his nominees to
the supreme court to quote unquote do
the right thing
and kind of things like that which they
say that makes them worry
and skeptical well you alluded to some
of the supreme court cases on the
horizon we've got
the vote now scheduled for next week
let's talk about the timeline
and why specifically for republicans
they want to get her confirmed
before a lot of these things on on the
horizon come to
present day so the senate judiciary
committee is going to be
voting on october 22nd to advance
barrett's nomination to the full senate
um so that said thursday
and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell said that the full senate will
begin
uh debate on her nomination the very
next day that's a friday so we do expect
that debate
to carry over into the following week
but also we expect that
you know that last full week of october
that that's when the full senate
will vote a final vote on barrett's
confirmation to the supreme court we do
expect that she will be confirmed
because
republicans do have enough votes to
accomplish that
and that is alex that was alexander
limon from washington d.c
next on politics now making their case
for congress
and when you look at the voting record
for susie lee you see that she voted 99
with with uh nancy pelosi and 95
with aoc dan rodimer tells us why he
says he's going to put nevada first
and the integrity of the election here
in the silver state we're also going to
hear from his
opponent suzy lee the incumbent on her
top priority
welcome back to politics now
the race in congressional district 3 it
has had the most money spent
and it's the most contentious it
features incumbent democrat susie lee
versus republican challenger dan rodimer
according to open secrets lee has spent
more than 788 thousand dollars for her
re-election
rodimer has spent 685
millions more has been spent by outside
groups now there is no candidate debate
in this race
the i-team's vanessa murphy interviewed
both candidates this week to help you
make an informed decision
here's her discussion with dan rodimer
can you name
three specific bills you would try to
pass
there's certain things that we need to
work on you know
right now and it's really pathetic
because you hear republicans
you know there's some republicans that
are you know uh on certain topics that i
get frustrated with
democrats you know i mean like social
security
they're like you know everybody's giving
up on it
i think there's no way i will ever ever
ever ever
vote on a bill that will defund or
or take away social security from our
seniors you know health care
you know right now you know i don't
believe in socialized medicine
i just don't you know suzie lee does i
do not i believe that
we should have you know competitive uh
health care
and you know i told everybody
you know i will never take anybody off
the current health care system i'll make
sure everybody has
good health care but or have health care
but you know i won't i will never vote
on anything
where you know they won't allow you to
come on
with a pre-existing condition we need to
protect these people
and a lot of republicans you know they
don't have a backbone to say
we're going to protect pre-existing
conditions
you know i'm very very passionate about
a few things er
you know social security you know health
care
jobs in school school is another one i
am
a huge advocate for school choice suzy
lee did not
agree to a debate what do you want to
say about that
well i think the people here in nevada
have the right
to hear from both sides i think they
should
um you know the fact is you know
uh my background yes i was a former wwe
pro wrestler
i was probably the worst wrestler in the
wwe but i was very good on the
microphone
and in law school when i went to law
school i was the best student i was a b
student i was very good at debating you
know these are the attributes that i
will bring
to congress you know in addition to
being a small business owner
here in nevada we own restaurants here
and
you know it's very very frustrating that
folks can't hear both sides
and right now all you're seeing is susie
lee is attacking me she's attacking my
family
on tv nonstop we've heard president
trump
uh question the integrity of this
election will you accept the election
results in nevada
look people come to me all the time and
they're worried about
fraud and they're worried about you know
um
ballot harvesting you know it's it's
illegal here i mean it is legal
you know people republicans argue about
it all the time well it's all right
but you know if that's the law of the
land
you can do it then you know you're going
to see folks out there doing it
um now do i think you know
if we find out that other people are
filling them out
and people are signing other people's
names and
they have proof of it and yes i would
expect
you know if it was either side i'd
expect suzy lee to do it or or
you know dan roadhammer to do it but
um i hope that there will not be
you know any any fraud and i encourage
everybody if you want your ballot to
count
you should probably go in person and
vote in person either early voting or
even absentee despite cobit 19
if you feel safe to go out
and vote in person early i would
recommend it
as rhodeimer mentioned he is a former
professional wrestler he and his wife
now own a vegan taco shop here in town
they have six kids
including one that was born less than a
month ago coming up next here on
politics now susie lee
lists her priorities as i've said before
i am a one issue congresswoman at this
point
we'll tell you what she says is her
number one priority in congress
you're watching politics now
we are back with more on the race in
congressional district 3.
democrat incumbent susie lee is taking
on republican challenger dan rodimer
and she spoke with the i-team's vanessa
murphy
and my first question is about some
endorsements
maybe unexpected like the review journal
uh chamber of commerce usually going
republican but they endorsed you what do
you want to say about that
well listen i am proud to have those
endorsements and i think it's a
reflection of the work that i've done in
congress since i've been there for two
years of really trying to work
uh with both parties across the aisle in
a bipartisan manner
to get things done that are so important
to nevada families and
i think there's a recognition that i'm
putting politics aside and trying to get
progress
and salt problems um as you know i
joined the problem solvers caucus which
is a caucus of 25 democrats
and 25 republicans when i first came to
congress
and really that was my commitment to the
constituents of congressional district 3
that they actually want to see a member
of congress
who's going to try to outreach and build
relationships
with members of both parties joe biden
finally
said he is not a fan of court
packing what are your thoughts
listen i you know my thoughts are right
now we are
faced with the most major
crisis at least in my lifetime in this
country this pandemic
families are on the brink of collapse
businesses
are on the brink of bankruptcy and
this administration is choosing to rush
through
supreme court hearings at this point
looking at basically being able to
place a justice on the court just in
time
for the supreme court hearing on the
affordable care act
which would take away protections for
pre-existing conditions
from millions of americans so i find it
that right now as i've said before i am
a one
issue congresswoman at this point i
think the biggest issue facing congress
right now
is making sure we get another package
past the finish line
onto the president's desk and signed
moving on to dan rodimer
one of his attack ads claims
that you are nancy pelosi's puppet
what do you want to say about that uh
dan rhodeimer is taking a book out of
the republican party playbook
and basically i think that my
endorsements speak for themselves
the review journal uh the chamber of
commerce
i've been ranked by the lugar center
which ranks
uh members based on their bipartisanship
as one of the most bipartisan
members of congress and so i think it's
a false attack
but it's basically one that is being
played all across this country
by my on you know by republicans who are
going after seats held by democrats and
um
you know but then you have to look at
what road eimer's
uh what road eimer's record is
and basically he's running on a record
of basically being pro-trump
and he's holding on to those coattails
and so i think it's an interesting
attack
you can watch more of the interview with
susie lee the congresswoman and dan
rodimer
her challenger at eightnewsnow.com look
for the 2020 election interviews tab and
while you're there check out interviews
with other candidates running for office
as well
las vegas sands review journal owner and
gop mega donor sheldon adelson making a
late in the game
splash in the presidential race
political reports adelson gave
75 million dollars to the anti-joe biden
super pac preserve america
that was about 90 percent of the group's
fundraising back in september
the center for responsive politics says
preserve america is now one of the
largest
outside spenders in politics that's
after the pro-biden super pac priorities
usa
and america first which supports
president trump
president trump back in nevada tomorrow
we're going to tell you about his rally
up in elko
and finally here on politics now here's
what we're keeping an eye on in what to
watch
president donald trump holding a rally
in northern nevada on sunday this is his
video
from the last rally he had in rural
nevada september 12th
in minden thousands of people were
attending there
sunday's rally is scheduled to be in
elko but it has since been moved to
carson city so we're going to watch to
see what the crowd size is up there
and whether it fits into nevada's covid
19 rules
we're also keeping an eye on early
voting and mail-in balloting
so far democrats have voted at a pace
three times that of nevada republicans
so we're watching to see if that keeps
pace or if republicans can
close the gap don't forget early voting
is now underway
in nevada and if you go online to
8newsnow.com you can find out all the
information you need to know
about voting registering and taking part
in the upcoming general election
that will do it for us here on politics
now we thank you very much for watching
don't forget you can keep
tabs on all the political news on
eightnewsnow.com and watch us
every saturday thank you very much
[Music]
you